guess what guys it's here the silk white
one plus six phone I am so excited about
this you guys know that when I did my
original unboxing I told you that this
was my most favorite color ever I was
gonna try to explain to you what it
looks like if you haven't seen it
already but I'm just gonna open it so
it's crazy because it said it had like
crushed pearls in it their press photos
do not do it justice at all and I'm not
even sure if you can see in this light I
try to zoom in a little bit it's got
this like iridescent shine to it
it has sort of these rose gold accents
which I think in the photos they looked
a little bit more pink or more rose gold
but in person it is a little bit more
subtle so it is more of like a lighter
pink color I do feel very speechless
because this is so good-looking
like it looks amazing and for me to say
this about a phone it's not an iPhone it
takes a lot so this definitely has
exceeded my expectations because I
thought that it was gonna be more of
like that sandstone finish
whereas this it is very very much like
an actual pearl it is smooth and it is
beautiful and now I guess we'll open up
the rest of the box even though you
already know what's in here if you've
watched my previous unboxing charging
brick my most favorite USB cable ever oh
it's a nice clear case very thoughtful I
feel - I'm definitely gonna get dirt
inside of here okay I'm taking the case
off just think about just taking a
little gander at how beautiful this
thing is
[Applause]
[Music]
structions SIM card ejector always
crucial I've honestly been really loving
my oneplus phone I've been using it as a
second device since I got it
and now we're gonna be opening up these
these are the bullet time I wanted to
say bullet time phones so the oneplus a
bullets Wireless I've really never used
any other wireless headphones
except for air pods before oh wow wow
wow wow oh look at that look at your
different colored he has all kinds of
different sized ear pieces here and this
looks like just a little carrying case a
little cable no way this is great I
haven't even got to the headphones yet
and I'm excited about all the
accessories this is gonna come in way
more handy than just charging these
headphones I feel like I've come oh
there we go these come on oops nope that
does not come out little tab oh there we
go that was easy
my cool now that's a nice fit put the
smaller little guys on for my teeny tiny
little ears oh yeah that's good that's
nice
jam that right in there so it makes
these special is their magnetic okay so
it makes these super special is their
magnetic so when they're connected
together they are not on or using power
when they're disconnected then they're
ready to use here's where you charge it
with that little USB cable and it looks
like it's already turned on so let's get
this thing paired up your inference will
automatically turn out and connect to
the last device they're paired with when
you separate them yes yes yes yes I
won't - yes okay great it's happening
everything is happening this is very
very very exciting pairing if Perry is
pairing yes they're okay right let's do
some journalism music we're gonna listen
to some tool if you guys are new here
they're one of my favorite bands new
only but you can listen to them is oh
wow this sounds so good
okay it sound really good I I can't
actually let you hear what it sounds
like but it sounds good and I'm
listening to a low-quality rip of a tool
album on YouTube wowee okay let's do
something Spotify because it'll be a
little bit better quality and you might
be wondering Justine why are you not
using your new oneplus phone yet because
I don't have it set up yet and
everything is already set up on this one
Fear Factory what mix is this cuz it's
really good machine had our Lady peace
System of a Down this is like my high
school this is really uninteresting for
you guys because you can't hear what I'm
hearing but I guess I could just say it
sounds good alright well that's that
let's try it out if I take these off
whoa Wow
so they aren't quite noise cancelling
but I've already slightly hard of
hearing so when I have these types of
headphones in I really can't hear much
at all that's why I do like ear pods or
headphones that don't entirely cover up
all of your ear because I then can't
hear anything
these are pretty awesome I'm definitely
excited to try these out a little bit
more let's put them in a little case get
in your home I'm having a lovely time
[Music]
thank you guys for watching OBS enjoyed
this I did wanted to show you this phone
because I was so excited about it during
the launch I'll see you guys in the next
video and just take one more look at it
just can you just can you just
appreciate the beauty feel like I should
exit to the James Blunt song you look
beautiful
there's other boxes of stuff that I've
unboxed I am a living fire hazard
[Music]